[Music]
today's question comes from jade in new
hampshire
jade writes my boyfriend and i do not
agree on money i'm 24 and he's 27 and
we've been together for three years
we constantly fight because he wants to
spend all his money and then my money
instead of putting some money in savings
i try to explain we need to be
financially stable by budgeting but he
says we are young and shouldn't worry
about saving money
genius
i've already started a retirement
account and i'm currently debt free
should we break up if we don't agree on
how to spend money or am i being
unreasonable
no you should break up
because you're married to an immature i
mean you're dating an immature child
keyword dating john there's so many red
flags here for a girlfriend and
boyfriend and he's spending her money
and they're trying to tell each other
what to do with their money
and they're trying to be financially
stable my guess is they're living
together based on just the situation
right there's just a lot of mess going
on here and uh it's not looking good as
far as the long-term outlook of this
relationship so let's go through this we
constantly fight
red flag i don't want to marry somebody
that we constantly fight during the
great years when we're dating when we
both still love each other right the
honeymoon period the honeymoon
we constantly fight
he spends all his money immature child
cannot does not have the adult
discipline to say hey i've tomorrow's
going to come the month after that's
going to come next year's going to come
i need to start planning
and then he takes your money
that's red flag number three because now
he's taking stuff it's not his and he's
taking it against
your wishes
he is
he's crossed he's bashing through your
boundaries
to get some of what you have already
said hey i want to plan long term i've
debt free i got retirement account and
he said i don't care what your
boundaries are i don't care what your
wishes are i want to feel good now and
this is going to come up with raising
kids buying a house live in a certain
town i don't care what job you want i
want to stay at home and
run
run
run and then keep running you're worth
more than this jade i got to give props
to uh zach running the graphics in the
booth the the lower third for this uh
question says should i dump my yolo
minded boyfriend the answer is yes and
when you put it that way i'm just gonna
say yes without context on that question
and the key word here is boyfriend now
they're not married there's nothing to
fight for here they're 24 and 27 you'll
be okay
i think if you can't get on the same
page about your financial values you got
to find someone who does have those
values
it's not even about financial advice
it's about
respect and dignity yeah and this man is
not treating you with respect and
dignity respect and dignity is about
we're going to plan together so we're
going to sacrifice the yolo now for
safety and security down the road it is
what do you what's going to make you
feel safe what's going to make you feel
loved and this guy cares about one thing
spending everybody's she is 24 he is 27
and she is still dating a child
that's not okay
time to go jade sorry there's other men
out there for you good luck